Les sens déterminent notre perception du monde.
Ils nous révèlent le goût d'une pomme,
les sensations ressenties par notre peau,
ainsi que notre vision du ciel.
Ils façonnent notre réalité.
Imaginons que nos sens soient interconnectés.
Le bruit d'une voiture aurait un goût de caramel.
À la vue d'un objet vert,
nous entendrions la note sol.
Ça flatterait nos oreilles, notre vue…
… et notre goût.
4,4% de la population
présente cette spécificité.
Si tel est votre cas, tout ce que je dis
peut vous sembler évident.
Si vous n'êtes pas concerné,
vous ne me croyez peut-être pas.
Il a fallu attendre l'année1987
pour que les scientifiques prouvent ce phénomène
avec les IRM.
Il est bien réel!
Ainsi, certains voient le mot "lundi" en rouge,
même si ça reste un mauvais jour pour tous.
Vous voulez savoir
si vous avez cette particularité?
Dites-moi combien vous voyez
de chiffres2 sur cette image.
Il y en a six.
Si les chiffres se présentent ainsi…
de sorte que vous puissiez distinguer les 2 des 5
en associant une couleur à chaque forme,
vous êtes synesthète.
Dans ce cas, pas d'inquiétude! Tout va bien.
C'est comme avoir des taches de rousseur.
Si vous n'avez pas réagi au test,
vous pouvez quand même être synesthète.
En effet, il existe de nombreuses variantes
de ce phénomène.
La synesthésie peut faire correspondre
des traits de personnalité avec des chiffres,
des chiffres avec des couleurs,
des couleurs avec des sons,
voire des douleurs avec des sons.
Aïe!
Elle peut associer des parfums et des couleurs,
ou des saveurs à un plaisir extrême.
Il existe au moins 70formes de synesthésie.
Van Gogh, Duke Ellington,
Kanye West, Marilyn Monroe…
… ou même, plus incroyable encore,
Pharell Williams…
… ont tous un point commun: la synesthésie.
Kanye West décrit son album "Yeezus"
comme une peinture sonore.
Pour Pharell Williams, le refrain de "Happy"
a des reflets roses, arc-en-ciel.
Si vous vous demandez pourquoi
autant d'artistes ont cette spécificité,
c'est peut-être qu'elle confère une perception
plus complète de la création artistique
et une approche différente de l'harmonie.
Le peintre russe Vassily Kandinsky
en est une bonne illustration.
Peintre du début des années1900,
Kandinsky était considéré comme un synesthète.
Certaines couleurs déclenchaient chez lui
la perception de sons ou de notes, et vice versa.
Un concert s'apparentait à un tourbillon de couleurs,
avec des points, des tirets et des traits
indiquant la progression de la musique.
Enfant, il entendait un chuintement en mélangeant
les couleurs de sa boîte de peintures.
Plus tard, il déclara que le son du violoncelle
représentait le bleu le plus foncé qui soit.
De nombreux artistes contemporains
tentent aujourd'hui de mettre cela en pratique.
Perry Hall en fait partie.
Ses peintures filmées en direct
reflètent son expérience synesthésique.
Puis-je réellement vivre
une expérience synesthésique?
Oui. La technologie permet de s'en approcher.
Instinctivement, on pense à un appareil,
tel que le BrainPort élaboré par Wicab.
Il convertit les informations vidéo en direct
en stimulations électriques légères,
captées sous forme de vibrations
ou de picotements sur la langue.
Les aveugles peuvent ainsi percevoir
leur environnement par le biais de la langue.
De son côté, l'ingénieur en aérospatiale
Zachary Howard a créé un masque utilisant
un capteur de couleurs, un microprocesseur
et des huiles essentielles pour goûter les sons.
Mais cela permet-il vraiment
de vivre une expérience synesthésique?
Mes sens seront-ils
réellement interconnectés?
Ou s'agira-t-il d'une pâle imitation?
À l'avenir, comment parviendrai-je à troubler
mes sens et à développer ma créativité?
Arriverai-je à désorienter mes sens
aussi facilement que cela?
Ou pourrons-nous aller encore plus loin
et nous doter d'un sens entièrement nouveau?
Et si nous disposions d'un capteur permettant
de voir les rayons infrarouges et ultraviolets?
Je vous présente Neil Harbisson.
Je suis un artiste cyborg.
L'art cyborg permet à l'individu
de créer ses propres sens
et ses propres organes sensoriels.
Pour ma part, je dispose
d'un nouvel organe sensoriel (une antenne)
et d'un nouveau sens me permettant de capter
les couleurs via la conduction osseuse,
et d'aller au-delà du spectre visuel,
c'est à dire des infrarouges aux ultraviolets.
Dans ma tête, grâce à une connexion Internet,
je peux recevoir des appels du monde entier.
Cela fonctionne également par satellite.
Vous servez-vous de ces capacités
pour vos créations artistiques?
Je m'approche du visage d'une personne.
J'écoute le son de ses yeux,
de ses lèvres, de ses cheveux et de sa peau,
puis j'élabore son portrait sonore.
Ensuite, au lieu d'envoyer une image du visage,
je transmets le son correspondant.
Incroyable! Vous disposez donc
véritablement d'un nouveau sens.
Puis-je moi-même devenir un cyborg?
Nous sommes tous des cyborgs psychologiques.
Entre nous et la technologie, il y a un lien
très fort, qui se transforme peu à peu
en union biologique. Bientôt, la cybernétique
et la technologie donneront naissance
à des individus augmentés biologiquement.
Des personnes dotées d'organes sensoriels
et de sens nouveaux. C'est déjà le cas.
Progressivement, nous trouverons normal
de rencontrer de tels individus.
Mais la synesthésie ne se résume pas à l'art,
à des jolies teintes, à des senteurs incroyables
ni à des explosions de couleurs.
Elle peut nous aider à plus grande échelle:
améliorer les facultés d'apprentissage,
favoriser la guérison des lésions cérébrales
et protéger du déclin mental lié à la vieillesse.
Dans le futur, nous pourrions tous bénéficier
de sens nouveaux qui n'existent pas encore!
Quels sens aimeriez-vous avoir?
Répondez-moi en laissant un commentaire
dans la section prévue à cet effet.
Au fait, je me réserve la vision à 360degrés,
cela va de soit!
Pour consulter d'autres sujets
relatifs à l'art et à la technologie,
cliquez sur le bouton "S'abonner".
Vous pourrez ainsi visionner d'autres vidéos.